welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and this is an explanation of the
ending and post-credited scenes for
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness a film that shocks us with what
exactly directed by sam raimi means
that's like we saw with wanda when your
dreams are finally within reach they are
ripped to shreds the spoiler warning in
case me saying i'm discussing the ending
post credit since this movie wasn't
clear enough because it will be spoiling
the entire multiverse of madness plot in
this video so if you haven't seen the
film and you need me to tell you this go
watch this movie on the biggest screen
you can it is amazing to look at i will
stay here waiting for you and thanks to
true bill for sponsoring today's video
more about them later so doctor strange
to the multiverse of madness says two
post-credits scenes but it's really the
madness that comes before throughout
this movie that we need to break down
first so in this movie one of maximov
seeking a universe with billy and tommy
hunts down america chavez for her
ability to travel the multiverse in the
opening scene leading to the death of
defender strange doctor strange reaches
out to her for help in doing so letting
her know exactly where america chavez is
and so she sacks camartage and strange
in america escape to earth 838 and
advanced utopian reality where they meet
mortar supreme and the rest of the
illuminati marvel's illuminati in the
comics is a six-member group of leaders
like the eu and world security council
in this case for superheroes seeking to
best defend earth in the mcu the lineup
is murder supreme replacing supreme
strange in this dimension died a hero
defeating thanos we think but also
captain carter this universe's first
avenger hayley atwell returning is peggy
carter playing a live-action version of
her what if character maria rambo
captain marvel defender of the cosmos
lashonna lynch returning from captain
marvel presumably a captain marvel were
in this universe she was irradiated by
the light speed engine instead of carol
danvers then black bolt leader of the
inhumans and keeper of the terrigen mist
ons and mount reprising his role from
abc's canceled inhuman series reed
richards aka mr fantastic of the
fantastic four with john krasinski
actually playing the role we've all been
fan casting for years head of the baxter
foundation where christine palmer works
alongside ultron centuries and then of
course this illuminati's founder charles
xavier professor x leader of the mutants
patrick stewart returning for the fox
x-men franchise but here in his olive
green suit and yellow hover chair from
the animated series so we learn how
their universe's stephen strange allowed
the dark hole to corrupt his soul
destroying universes in an incursion
forcing black bolts to destroy him with
a whispered i'm sorry since of course
black bolts voice can level mountains
and this illuminati lied enshrining
strange as a hero meanwhile wanda uses
the dark hole to dreamwalk aka possess
the bodies of one of her variant selves
from another universe and wrecks the
illuminati sealing black bolt's mouth
neo-style so he obliterates his own
brain unraveling read richard's elastic
body like ribbon severing captain carter
at the midsection with her own shield
crushing captain marvel under rubble and
then professor x tries to rescue wanda
inside her mind but the scarlet witch
snaps his neck why
so strange christine in america trying
to get to the book of ashanti but wanda
snatches america and bans the stranger
christine to a post-incursion universe
where strange meets a sinister strange
third eye opens on his forehead a
twisted evil manifestation showing how
this guy's soul has been corrupted by
the darkhold the two strangest duel with
music and strange blast three hides
strange out the window impaling him on a
fence below yet the third eye opens
because the soul of the damned remains
alive so then strange uses this
universe's dark hole to dreamwalk into
that corpse of defender strange over to
the temple on wounded war mountain to
confront wanda and save america in doing
so he exposes his own soul to the souls
of the damned and eventually manages to
harness these souls into a replacement
cloak it is sick america punches wanda
back into west view making billy and
tommy see her as a monster in our wanda
finally realizing her mistakes implodes
the temple and destroys the darkholds in
every reality america is left a sorcerer
in training at camertaj and strange
takes a morning stroll but then suddenly
a third eye opens on his forehead and he
screams this leads to a post-credit
scene where strange is greeted by the
sorceress clea played by charlize their
own who tells him that he created an
incursion and they need to fix it she
opens a rift to the dark dimension and
strange who now proudly opens that third
eye joins her unafraid now in the comics
clea is the sorcerer's supreme of the
dark dimension niece to uncle dormammu
who becomes a major partner to strange
and eventually his spouse it was only a
matter of time before cleo joined the
mcu and her and this movie's repeated
use of the word incursion is super
important as it points to a possible
secret wars crossover event on the
horizon in the secret wars comics all
the marvel heroes and villains are
respawned on a multiversal plane called
battle world in the more recent 2015
version of the events it was dr doom who
oversees this in the original 80's story
line it was the beyonder now there is a
second post-credits scene with bruce
campbell's cameo as pizza papa papa
john's style pizza ball street vendor in
the illuminati dimension of earth 838
whom strange left cursed so that his
left fist kept punching his own face an
homage to sam raimi and bruce campbell's
past work in the evil dead series and
ash's infamous cursed severed hand that
attacks him strange earlier said that
the spell would last three weeks and
here we are three weeks later his pizza
balls melted the spell wears off and he
turns to camera with the meta
declaration of it's over now if you're
hoping for a multiversal version of
yourself that's better with money we'll
jump through a portal to help you sort
your finances out our friends at
truebill are here to help with a more
realistic solution truebill is an
all-in-one finance platform that helps
you save more and spend less through the
app you can track your expenses manage
subscriptions lower your bills and build
your savings all in one place i really
like how easy truebill makes it to
safely and securely identify recurring
charges and cancel unwanted
subscriptions with just a tap it's also
got some nice credit score monitoring
tools to give you a little nudge when
something unusual might be happening it
won't alert you if a multiversal version
of you is trying to steal your identity
but it will help with lots of other
stuff truebill can also help you create
a custom budget that automatically
monitors your spending by category such
as dining out or entertainment they'll
send you friendly notifications when
you've exceeded your budget and you can
even visualize your spin to earn ratio
in the app get started with true build
today by heading to truebill.com new
rockstars or by clicking the link in the
video description that's truebuild.com
new rockstars folks there is so much to
unpack from this film and we will in the
days ahead trust me but some quick
takeaways we gotta address here the
illuminati of this movie exists in
marvel earth 838 and this movie finally
identifies the main mcu as earth-616
a designation until now only hinted at
like with the label on the film strip of
loki's timeline in loki episode 1 and in
spider-man far from home when the
imposter mysterio quentin beck claimed
he was from dimension 833 and then this
dimension was 616 which now makes it
pretty coincidental that quentin beck
and guterman pick the actual multiversal
numerical designation out of a hat okay
either way this means that in the mcu
multiverse exists one universe at least
where mutants the fantastic four the
inhumans in the territory mist and
captain carter all co-exist and things
like mutants terrigen mist the negative
zone if they exist in one dimension they
can exist in others target missed in the
comics is famously how characters like
miss marvel are created it seems like
the mcu version of that is going to go
in a different direction yet still
deregin myths exist in the mcu folks
mutants exist in the mcu x-men are
coming still not here but they're coming
and if all these things can exist in the
mcu hopefully so too can living versions
of some of these brutally murdered
members of the illuminati like i imagine
this might be a one-time reprisal for
patrick stewart but lynch atwell wore
those suits with confidence my friends
and krasinsky as reed richards notably
mentioned having a wife and children
referring to sue storm the invisible
woman and their child franklin richards
a key omega-level mutant in the comics
and implying a lineage of descendants
that will eventually lead to nathaniel
richards aka kang to conqueror actually
the recent news that john watts has
stepped down from directing the mcu
fantastic four movie has led many to
speculate that john krasinski could take
over as actor director as he's done an
amazing job with the two a quiet place
films and has previously expressed
interest now remains to be seen if
krasinski will be the mcu's reed
richards in every universe or just this
one and a different actor will play the
character in the future as the mcu at
this point has shown how multiversal
variants can be played either by the
same actor or different ones and that
same uncertainty applies to how the mcu
will introduce the x-men patrick stewart
just seems like a fan service return
from a beloved era and maybe less like a
harbinger of other past era x-men and
mutants that kevin feige will bring back
and other than ryan reynolds deadpool
there seemed to be no other plans to
bring back like hugh jackman or james
marsden or halle berry as of yet the
options remain open but quickly on the
three-eyed strange and clea so strange's
third eye likely indicates that his soul
remains cursed and bonded with the souls
of the damned and whatever evil spirits
surrounded the darkhold despite the
darkholds being destroyed in every
dimension whatever evil lurks through
them imbued into those pages from the
curses drafted by cathan remain living
in doctor strange i mean even after the
climax of this movie strange seemed to
be in a bit of denial about what
lingering effects of his embracing the
souls of the damned would mean for him
going forward and the fact that he's now
at peace with this curse suggests that
he sees it as more of a power the next
stage of his evolution him facing his
fears so what awaits them in the dark
dimension well maybe an incursion
resulting in dr doom's battle world and
avengers 5 secret wars or maybe the guy
who famously loves torturing the damned
or since kevin feige recently confirmed
loki in the removal of that kang variant
he who remains was the initial cause of
this madness and the hint of reed
richard's lineage the beneficiary of
these incursions might be kang the
conqueror again a lot to talk about
folks and my easter egg breakdown of
this film is coming to the channel
tomorrow i think followed by days weeks
and a months ahead of us continuing to
unpack this epic film follow me on
instagram and twitter at eavos follow
new rockstar subscribe to new rockstars
for more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you